salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux vous le savez j'adore partager
avec vous mes connaissances sur les
animaux aujourd'hui je vous propose mon
top 5 des animaux dotés d'un super
pouvoir ça vous dit alors c'est parti
[Musique]
les curieux ce sympathique rongeur qui
vit dans nos forêts n'a rien à envier à
chip le génial écureuils de crypto et
les super animaux il possède une mémoire
d'éléphant vous savez peut-être les
écureuils ni berne pas pour tenir le
choc en hiver il constitue l' des
réserves des noisettes des glands des
insectes ou des champignons qu'ils
enfouissent un peu partout dans le sol
ils peuvent constituer jusqu'à 3000
réserve des cachettes qu'ils doivent
mémoriser pas simple me direz vous et
pourtant les écureuils y parviennent
comment font-ils on a longtemps pensé
que cette prouesse était lié un odorat
particulièrement développée c'est faux
les scientifiques ont découvert qu'il
possède une mémoire spatiale
exceptionnelle pour se souvenir de ses
gâchettes l'écureuil roux adoptent une
stratégie appelée hunting que l'on peut
traduire par
mémorisation par bloc il commence par
entassé ses réserves en un seul endroit
puis il les réparties dans différents
lieux en fonction de leur nature des
noisettes où sont stockés dans une zone
des champignons dans une autre etc etc
il se forge ainsi une carte mentale de
ses cachettes ce qui lui permet de
retrouver ses provisions sans aucune
difficulté cerise sur le gâteau ce petit
malin dissimulent les aliments à haute
valeur nutritive le plus loin possible
de la source de nourriture de cette
manière dit minimise les chances de se
faire dérober son trésor
quel panache
2 le lézard basilique à vue de nez rien
ne le distingue des multiples espèces de
lézards qui peuplent les forêts
d'amérique centrale il possède une jolie
couleur verdoyante
que et deux aigrettes qui lui donne
l'alluré d'un petit dinosaure et
pourtant basilisk lui unifrance ce sont
avant tout les classes dans les arts
comme les autres il possède un super
pouvoir unique chez les reptiles se les
arbitres à proximité les cours d'eau
lorsqu'il se sent menacé plutôt que de
prendre ses jambes à son trou et de
s'enfuir dans la forêt il se dresse sur
ses pattes arrière et se met à courir
sur l'eau ce qui lui vaut un autre
surnom lézard jésus-christ et pour cause
selon les évangiles jésus aurait marché
sur l'eau cette aptitude est d'autant
plus surprenante que ce petit sauriens
de 90 cm peut peser jusqu'à 200 grammes
et 200 grammes ce n'est pas rien en
toute logique il devrait couler à pic
alors comment fait-il il n'y a aucun
miracle dans cette histoire cette
prouesse est liée à la forme de ses
pattes arrière elles sont pourvues de
très longs doigts lorsque ceux ci sont
déployés et écarter une offre pour les
arts une grande surface de contact avec
l'eau un peu comme des pales par
ailleurs lorsque ses pattes frappe la
surface de l'eau une bulle d'air se
forment en dessous ce qui ralentit
l'enfoncement ajoutez à cela une foule
est extrêmement rapide pas plus de 70000
secondes par page et le lézard parvient
à courir sur l'eau sans aucune
difficulté en revanche s'il ralenti il
va finir à la nage aucun problème pour
lui se font plus on est même capable de
tenir millièmes de milan ac n'est
puisque nous sommes sous l'eau reste on
vit avec notre troisième animal aux
super pouvoirs ou de transformistes de
génie est la pieuvre mimétique
ce céphalopode a été découvert en 1998
sur les côtes indonésiennes il vit sur
les fonds sableux et mesure une
soixantaine de centimètres
la plupart de ses congénères cette
pieuvre capable de changer de couleur en
un clin d'oeil grâce à des cellules
spécialisées sur sa peau ce tour ne
passe passe lui permet de chasser et de
se protéger d'éventuels prédateurs mais
tome octopus lennik us son avance ne se
contente pas de se fondre dans le décor
elle est aussi capable de prendre la
forme des animaux qui partage son
habitat pour imiter une seule par
exemple elle regroupe ses huit bras en
un faisceau de la même forme que
l'animal elle ressemble alors à une
seule plate qui ondule dans l'eau pour
ressembler au serpent de mer un
prédateur dont le venin est mortelle
elle change ses rayures brune et blanche
en rayures jaunes et noirs puis elle
enfouit sa tête ainsi que six de ses
tentacules dans le sable il ne lui reste
plus qu'à jeter frénétiquement ses deux
derniers tentacules pour simuler la
présence du reptile c'est à s'y
méprendre et cette stratégie s'avère
payante est les prédateurs réfléchisse à
deux fois avant d'attaquer ironie de
l'histoire les scientifiques viennent
d'identifier un petit poisson capable de
prendre la forme des tentacules de la
pieuvre mimétique le starlix et ce trio
bénéficient ainsi de la protection
probablement involontaire de cet as du
déguisement tel est pris qui croyait
prendre retour sur terre pour notre
quatrième animal aux super pouvoirs
je vais vous parler d'un insecte malgré
son poids plume il envoie du lourd le
bousier taureau il s'agit d'un petit
coléoptère de la famille des scarabées
que l'on trouve en europe et en asie il
tient son nom de la grande paire de
cornes qui ornent la tête de certains
mal mais ce n'est pas à ce niveau que se
nichent son super pouvoir il se cache
dans ses biscotos le bousier est en
effet doté d'une force herculéenne
ce minuscule insecte qui ne pèse que
quelques grammes est capable de pousser
les boules d'excréments 1140 fois plus
lourde que lui c'est comme si je
parvenais à déplacer une roche de cas
tre 20 tonnes l'équivalent de deux semi
remorques évidemment c'est impossible
même pour l'homme le plus fort du monde
alors comment fait il et bien pour
réussir cet exploit l'insecte commence
par fabriquer une énorme boule composé
de déjections qui collecte dans son
environnement de la crotte d'éléphants
par exemple une fois que la boule et
bien formés et bien compact il prend
appui sur le sol à l'aide de ses pattes
avant puis il pousse son fardeau avec
ses pattes arrière bref pour avancer il
recule vous me suivez et ça marche enfin
ça roule alors vous allez me dire
pourquoi ce diable de bouvier passe-t-il
séjourné à pousser des matières fécales
et bien il se trouve que c'est un coach
of ages un animal qui se nourrit
uniquement d'exclure chacun ses goûts
c'est aussi un insecte très utile en
modérant sa nourriture ils jouent un
rôle essentiel dans la fertilisation des
sols et la dispersion des graines
qu'elle contient rien ne se perd tout se
recycle 1,5 on finit avec un feu
d'artifice
je vous présente
appauvri ni d'ail un poisson pète le feu
faudrait plutôt dire qu'ils crachent le
feu il l'aimait de magnifiques jets de
lumière bleue qui sortent de sa bouche
et font penser à des boules de feu cela
lui vaut un autre surnom le poisson
cracheurs de lumière ce petit poisson
transparents vis dans les profondeurs
océaniques un monde sans lumière où la
discrétion est de rigueur ne pas être vu
dans son environnement est une question
de vie ou de mort dans ce cas pourquoi
métier tout en oeuvre pour se faire
repérer s'agirait-il une stratégie
ingénieuse pour impressionner ses
prédateurs pas du tout au contraire même
lorsqu'il produit ce g lumineux à pogo
nida est en réalité victime d'un petit
crustacé très indigeste l'australie
sentant sa dernière venue le crustacé
déclenché un mécanisme de défense plutôt
brillant il s'allume leurs codes
déclenche une réaction chimique à
cugnaux luminescentes semblable à celle
de ver luisant elle met en jeu une
molécule spécial qu'on appelle la lucie
ferraz y réagit avec l'oxygène dans les
maisons de la lumière or il se trouve
que cette lumière très vive représente
un vrai danger pour notre poisson
souvenez vous il est transparent
éclairée de l'intérieur le voilà tout à
coup repérable par ces prédateurs pour
sauver sa peau ou plutôt ses écailles à
pogo nida et n'a d'autre choix que de
régurgiter l'intrus dans un rond
magistral celui ci alors la forme d'un
jet de lumière du plus bel effet la
gourmandise est un vilain défaut provost
nida et nous en apportent la preuve
lumineuse merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout c'est le meilleur
soutien que vous pouvez apporter à la
chaîne et si vous connaissez d'autres
animaux super pouvoirs qu'ils auraient
leur place dans ce top ne vous privez
pas laisser un commentaire j'ai hâte de
vous lire
en attendant je vous invite à découvrir
les super pouvoirs de crypto et ses amis
en salles le 27 juillet ah j'allais
oublier n'hésitez pas non plus à vous
abonner à très bientôt cher épi
curieuses et curieux
[Musique]
j'ai perdu ma d'héroïsme ils sont pas
doués tout simplement ils sont plus
forts au ce que tu crois des poils
bouclier car c'est quoi le bouclier
calmels
qui avait changé ses pouvoirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]